[Musik]
alles in allem haben wir damit heute
einen ganz großen maßnahmenkatalog wie
ich finde verabredet ich sage allerdings
die lage ist hochdramatisch und es wird
jetzt sehr darauf ankommen dass schnell
gehandelt wird das konsequent gehandelt
wird das besser kontrolliert wird und
dann wird man beobachten müssen ob wir
die dynamik damit stoppen oder zumindest
reduzieren können das geschieht jetzt
auch zu einem zeitpunkt wo es darauf
ankommt und es wird nicht stück für
stück geschehen sondern gewissermaßen in
einem großen grund einer großen
anstrengung die überall in deutschland
unternommen wird herzlich willkommen zu
einem zdf spezial
heute war es also wieder soweit
krisentreffen von bund und ländern
angesichts extrem angestiegenen zahl von
neuinfektionen
die vierte welle stopp möglichst
einheitliche maßnahmen wollten die
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidentinnen mit der bundeskanzlerin
beschließen geeinigt hat man sich auf
einen höheren schutz von bewohnern wie
zb in alten und pflegeheimen unter
anderem durch eine strenge tests pflicht
für mitarbeiter und besucher außerdem
soll es ein pflege bonus geben das
impfangebot soll ausgeweitet werden
bundesweit kommt 3g am arbeitsplatz und
homeoffice überall möglich 3g kommt
jetzt auch im personennahverkehr und in
zügen im fokus dabei immer die
hospitalisierung rate steigt sie über
drei wird der zugang zur
freizeitveranstaltungen oder
gastronomischen einrichtungen
eingeschränkt also zweig eintritt nur
für geimpfte und genießen steigt die
rate höher auf 6 oder 9 gelten noch
schärfere maßnahmen auch kontakt
beschränkungen sind dann möglich
und über die ergebnisse wollen wir jetzt
mit dem bayerischen ministerpräsidenten
markus söder sprechen guten abend
also da würden sie mich
ach das geht noch nicht
wir sind schon auf sendung
kann vielleicht jemand dann soll der
bescheid geben dass wir schon
wer könnte
der kontakt ist erstmal weg dann machen
wir weiter und reden gleich mit ihm es
ist vor allem die dramatische situation
überlasteten krankenhäusern die die
politik zum handeln sinkt besonders
betroffen neben bayern auch sachsen
thomas bärsch berichtet
es sind momente wie diese die es dem
pflegeteam auf der intensivstation im
dresdner uniklinikum so schwer machen zu
unberechenbar jede pflegekraft ist
ausgelastet und dann fällt plötzlich in
einem bett der blut sauerstoffgehalt
das ist
eigentlich eine reanimation situation
so lenz echtes blut
überlebt man nicht sehr lange und wenn
man alle register schon gezogen hat das
heißt also die beatmung schon eskaliert
hat und alles andere schon probiert hat
bleibt für uns
als letzte option
die herz-lungen-maschine eine maschine
die das blut aus dem körper holt es mit
sauerstoff angereichert und zurück pumpt
den job an ihr kann nicht jeder machen
schon gar nicht ohne ausbildung und
training da wiegt es umso schwerer dass
der stationsleiter auch immer wieder mit
ansehen muss wenn seine leute diesem
stress eben nicht gewachsen sind und
gehen auch das heißt überlastung wir
verlieren jedes jahr welche ich habe
auch welche mit der klaren begründung
verloren so was wie diese wellen vom
winter kann ich nicht nochmal
das setzen zu sehr zu das hat nichts
mehr mit dem zu tun was wir vorher
gemacht haben
was man irgendwie akzeptieren muss noch
hat sachsen die lage im griff sagt
verlegt patienten doch nähert sich der
freistaat mit riesenschritten dem tag an
dem es für probleme eben keine lösungen
ergeben könnte auf ein datum festlegen
die sich kein ort auch der zeitraum ist
umrissen wenn wir uns die patienten
belegungszahlen auf die normalstation
anziehen dann wissen wir quasi wie bei
uns die welt in ein zwei wochen aussieht
und das ist ja auch das warum wir jetzt
eben schon mit mit sorge in die zukunft
blicken heute kriegen wir die patienten
hier noch gut versorgt das ist aber
nicht gesagt dass es in einer woche oder
in zwei wochen eben auch machen ist 14
tage würde in etwa auch ein lockdown
brauchen um seine wirkung zu entfalten
für viele hier gilt das als
unumgängliche ausweg ein ausweg auch für
pflegekräfte von denen sich manche wie
in einer zeitschleife gefangen fühlen
nach der ersten zweiten dritten nun in
der vierten welle die sich für viele
hier auch heute nicht aufkommen müssen
80 90
und dann denke ich mir wenn du dich
jetzt impfen lassen die patienten dann
wärs denn die hier bei mir dann würdest
du vielleicht zu hause husten und fieber
haben und willst dich 14 tagen ins bett
legen aber den hedge überstanden
22 blöcken sind derzeit mit patienten
belegt 20 von ihnen ohne impfschutz acht
betten sind noch frei doch das ist nur
der stand heute abend
darüber reden möchte ich jetzt in berlin
mit dem vorsitzenden der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft gut nahm der
gast
wir haben die dramatische situation in
sachsen gesehen in österreich bereitet
man sich schon auf eine trias vor also
das entschieden werden muss wer noch
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
kann könnte es in deutschland auch bei
so weit kommen ja es ist leider so dass
trias ja keinen punkt ist den man quasi
auf einen schlag erreicht sondern das
geht schleichend voran und wir wissen
dass heute schon in den überlasteten
kliniken entschieden wird welche
patienten früher als eigentlich geplant
von dem intensivstationen zurückverlegt
werden auf normal stationen und das ist
natürlich der erste schritt ein wenn man
nicht mehr optimal versorgen kann und
insofern wird die situation dort wo die
hohen instanzen sind und die hohen
belegungen jedem tag schlimmer würde bei
einer trial stände auch zwischen
gamestar und ungeimpft entschieden
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass
wir so weit kommen es muss jetzt dazu
kommen dass wirklich sehr schnell und
geordnet auch verlegungen erfolgen aus
den regionen die sehr stark belastet
sind um platz zu schaffen für neue
notfallpatienten sie haben vorhin in
ihrer nachrichten gezeigt wie der
rettungsdienst zur zeit nach freien
betten sucht auch das ist natürlich dann
ein punkt der zu schäden bei anderen
patientinnen und patienten führt und das
bedeutet dass wir jetzt auch wirklich
regional und überregional reagieren
müssen ja was halten sie denn von den
beschlossenen maßnahmen heute reicht das
aus
zunächst mal müssen wir wirklich
feststellen dass der streit der
politische streit der letzten tag viel
schaden angerichtet hat viel vertrauen
verspielt hat und dass unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
kliniken was nicht mehr verstanden haben
hier ging es weniger um die sache als
ums prinzip
wir erwarten jetzt nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von heute
dass dieser streit wirklich beendet wird
das auch im bundesrat jetzt beschlossen
wird und dass dann die bundesländer
konsequent die notwendigen
entscheidungen treffen wirklich die
planungen für die booster impfungen mit
aller kraft voran bringen und natürlich
auch dort wo es notwendig ist kontakt
beschränkungen umsetzen was wir reden
gleich weiter eine wichtige rolle soll
ja auch der hospitalisierung index
spielen als kennziffer für weitergehende
schutzmaßnahmen was dahintersteckt kurz
erklärt von svenja bergerhoff
seit einiger zeit schauen wir auf eine
neue kennzahl die hospitalisierung
incidents sie gibt an wie viele corona
patienten pro 100.000 einwohner
innerhalb von sieben tagen ins
krankenhaus eingewiesen wurden die
hospitalisierung incident soll so nicht
nur die belegung der intensivstation
sondern die insgesamte situation in den
kliniken zeigen denn viele kranke kommen
zumindest zunächst auf normale station
der bisherige höchststand wurde letztes
jahr an heiligabend mit 15,75 erreicht
heute liegt der wert bundesweit bei 5,3
doch es gibt große regionale
unterschiede in hamburg gibt das lka die
rate heute mit 1,62 an in thüringen mit
18,54 kritik gibt es an der kennzahl
unter anderem wegen ihrer berechnung in
die aktuelle hospitalisierung incidents
fließen nämlich nur die eingewiesenen
patienten mit ein die auch innerhalb der
letzten sieben tage positiv getestet
wurden oft liegen aber mehr als sieben
tage zwischen test und einweisung diese
patienten fallen aus der aktuellen
incidents heraus so wird die lage in den
krankenhäusern kontinuierlich
unterschätzt
wie wichtig ist für sie die
hospitalisierung skate wie sinnvoll ist
sie als maßstab für schutzmaßnahmen 3 6
und 9 werden jetzt als schwellenwerte
genannt sie ist im grunde nach wichtig
und richtig aber der bericht hat gezeigt
wir haben im moment wirklich auch noch
eine mögliches defizit in der erfassung
bis zum heutigen tag gibt es kein
digitales meldeverfahren in dem die
krankenhäuser täglich über eine software
an die gesundheitsämter melden sondern
das ganze wird nach wie vor in papier
per fax übermittelt und insofern
erklären sich dann auch diese
wahnsinnigen unterschiede die die reale
situation nicht abbilden wir schauen
deshalb nach wie vor auf die inzidenz
'nen und auf die belegung der
intensivstation wir müssen jetzt
dringend diese defizite im
meldeverfahren aber auch bei der frage
an welchem punkt wird gemeldet wirklich
nachbessern um dann ein einheitliches
system zu haben und wirklich
vergleichbare hospitalisierung daten
also da ist noch wahnsinnig viel zu tun
vielleicht noch ganz kurz was sagen sie
zu einer impfpflicht für beschäftigte in
kliniken und in der pflege wir sprechen
uns dafür aus wir haben dafür geworben
dass der ethikrat dazu eine
stellungnahme abgibt das hat er jetzt
getan er hat sich da positiv
positioniert und wir werten das als
deutsche krankenhausgesellschaft
unterstützen und bei unseren
mitarbeitern dafür werben dass sie sich
jetzt wirklich impfen lassen es sind
nicht viele in den krankenhäusern aber
auch die versuchen wir jetzt nochmal zu
überzeugen um sie nicht zu verlieren
vielen dank reckers
so und jetzt probiere ich es nochmal
herr söder können sie mich in jetzt
hören
ja sehr gut guten abend in bayern ist
die lage ja besonders dramatisch
bekommen sie die vierte welle mit den
maßnahmen heute in den griff
die maßnahmen die heute beschlossen
worden sind haben wir alle schon längst
gemacht und umgesetzt also das ist zwar
wichtig dass einige zusatzpunkte kommen
mehr ausfall hilfen für betroffene
unternehmen ein pflege boni der
vereinbart werden soll das alles ist gut
aber im grunde genommen glaube ich dass
es nicht reichen wird sowohl der
beschluss heute auf der mpk als auch das
bundesgesetz des neuen ich das ja auch
nachgebessert wurde es wird nicht im
ernst der lage angemessen dargestellt
also wir brauchen glaube ich sehr bald
eine nachbesserung de facto muss es ein
lockdown für ungeimpfte sein wir haben
vor einem beitrag der gehört dass fast
90 prozent auf den intensivstationen
ungeimpfte sind bei uns ist sehr sehr
sehr stark dort wo niedrige impfquote
ist die infektion ganz besonders hoch
insofern muss es dort auch entsprechende
kontakt beschränkungen und über 2g
hinausgehen auch noch zweig plus
maßnahmen geben
angesichts der dramatik der krise war
das heute ein konstruktives gespräch
auch über parteigrenzen hinweg
ja das waren konstruktiv kann man sagen
die ampel hat auch nach anfänglichem
zögern ja ihren gesetzentwurf verbessert
auch das was heute jetzt vorgelegt wurde
ist in jedem fall besser als vorher wir
glauben immer noch nicht dass es ganz
leicht so debatten ist es jetzt eine
epidemische lage oder nicht ist
angesichts solcher zahlen eine relativ
absurde diskussion es gibt auch
systembrüche im gesetz also theater
sollen anschließend aber die gastro
nicht da gibt es natürlich paar punkte
liegt stimmen trotzdem ist es besser als
vorher das muss man anerkennen
respektieren deswegen wird es mal noch
ein bundesrat eine große zustimmung
geben das heißt sie und die anderen
unions länder werden dem
infektionsschutzgesetz morgen zu stemmen
also bayern auf jeden fall und mein
eindruck ist dass die meisten anderen
länder das auch tun wir haben ja auch
keine zeit jetzt zu verschwenden es muss
also schnell wie möglich umgesetzt
werden ich werde für bayern neuen frühen
zur koalition zusammen berufung darauf
aufbauend und auch mit der tatsache dass
man noch aus alten rechtsrahmen
schöpfung kann für die nächsten drei
wochen noch mal ein paket schnüren das
bei uns auch der lage angemessen ist das
im prinzip unter zwei begriffen läuft
das eine ist blocken also die infektion
verlangsamen und booster dem impf turbo
anzulegen damit noch mehr geimpft werden
kann zum glück gehen die impfzahlen
wieder hoch das ist sehr sehr gut aber
wir müssen das noch mal mit 15 darunter
die uhr machen viele bundesländer haben
gar keine impfzentren mehr wir hatten
die behalten fahren die jetzt auch
entsprechend hoch und zum glück hat die
stiko ist auch endlich nach einigen
monaten die empfehlung gegeben nicht nur
ab 70 sondern generell ab 18 zu ostern
insofern glaube ich ist es schon ein
wichtiger tag ob es ausreicht ich bin
skeptisch wir werden sie ja wir wollen
sie denn dafür sorgen dass jetzt
wirklich jeder der geimpft werden will
schnell eine impfung bekommt sie
sprechen es an sie haben schon viele
hochgefahren aber auch in bayern warten
ja auch viele ältere bereit noch auf
ihre dritte impfung
wir haben dann zweigeteilt ist das eine
sind tatsächlich noch niedrige impfquote
bei erste und zweite impfung gott sei
dank zieht es da auch an und ist zwei
dass aufgrund der impf durchbrüche das
boostern wir haben uns immer dafür
ausgesprochen jeden zu ostern der es
braucht und der es will die impfzentren
werden jetzt maximal hochgefahren
wichtig ist auch dass den ärzten das
risiko genommen wird da waren einige
sehr zurückhaltend das risiko ohne eine
stiko empfehlung das ist jetzt ab heute
besser damit wird die impfungen den
arztpraxen besser wir gehen in bayern
sogar noch weiter wir übernehmen die
komplette haftung nicht nur erst ab
sechs sondern sogar fünf monaten zu
impfen das heißt kapazitäten werden
hochgefahren die freiheit wird
geschaffen alles und jeden zu impfen so
dass wir hoffen dass wir bis weihnachten
ganz ganz großen teil entsprechend
mussten können
wie schützt man angesichts steigender
zahlen vor allem kranke ältere
pflegebedürftige eine impfpflicht für
bestimmte beschäftigte wird vehement
gefordert zum beispiel in pflegeheimen
zudem soll es dort wieder eine
testpflicht geben über sorgen und
diskussionen in einem altenheim in
hamburg lebt immer man von sievert
noch ist die stimmung gut
aber die sorge vor dem virus und die
sorge vor erneuter einsamkeit sie
spielen immer mit in diesen tagen für
die bewohnerinnen und bewohner des
hospitals zum heiligen geist ist corona
wieder das rede thema viel verständnis
herrscht nicht unter ihnen was die
mangelnde bereitschaft einer kleinen
minderheit angeht sich impfen zu lassen
dann finde ich
auch auf der leitungsebene der
traditionsreichen hamburger
altenpflegeeinrichtung ist von
inzwischen zum klartext übergegangen in
sachen impfpflicht für mitarbeitende
wenn es ethisch und auch juristisch
abgeklärt ist wenn ich mittlerweile
wirklich auch ein verfechter einer
impfpflicht für den gesundheitsbereich
das muss ich wirklich sagen weil ich
hoffe einfach dass es dadurch gelingt
unsere uns anvertrauten senioren
pflegebedürftigen menschen wirklich vor
einer infektion zu bewahren und dennoch
schwingt gleichzeitig eine weitere sorge
mit
es gibt sowieso einen personalmangel in
den im bereich pflege was passiert dann
also das ist ein bisschen ich bin da so
ein bisschen zwiegespalten muss ich
sagen weil ich natürlich angst habe dass
uns mitarbeiter deswegen verlassen
werden das heim eigene testzentrum wird
in den nächsten tagen wohl weiter
aufgerüstet denn kontinuierliche tests
sind über die impfung hinaus das a und o
für die sicherheit bei denen auch in
hamburg deutlich steigenden instanzen
also ich wünsche mir dass wir für
öffentliche veranstaltung wir haben hier
im hospital auch zahlreiche
festivitäten beziehungsweise außer
zusammenkünfte dass es da eine strikte
zweig plus regelung gibt das heißt dass
es nur noch für genesene für geimpfte
mit einem aktuellen test ergebnis dann
möglich ist an diesen veranstaltungen
teilzunehmen
36 menschen sind allein hier an oder mit
dem virus gestorben alle vor der impfung
und seite impfung gab es nicht eine
infektion
ja und zugeschaltet ist jetzt der
regierende bürgermeister von berlin
michael müller genannt schon genannt die
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
also für beschäftigte in pflegeheimen
und krankenhäusern soll kommen so die
forderung wie schnell kann das gehen
ja das muss jetzt noch mal sicherlich
auch juristisch alles überprüft werden
das ganze verfahren welche verordnung
welche mal gesetze man braucht aber es
war heute ein eindeutiges signal der
länder und auch von der bundesebene
urlaub schulz hat das ganz deutlich
gemacht und im beitrag wurde dass er
eben auch unterstrichen es ist richtig
dass die beschäftigten in diesen
sensiblen bereich nimmt auch geimpft
sein müssen wir wollen das jetzt
vorantreiben ich glaube es kann sehr
schnell gehen
ein paar tage der bundestag die länder
werden sich damit jetzt befassen ich
kann ihnen das nicht auf den tag genau
sagen aber es ein wichtiges signal das
wir haben ja doch über einige wochen
muss man sagen überlegt wie die effekte
sind und ob es nicht vielleicht sogar so
ist das eingeläutet dann verschränkt
sind und hinschmeißen aber es wir haben
eine absurde situation ja wo die
bewohner von pflegeeinrichtungen die
besucher sind alle geimpft getestet und
dann teilweise die beschäftigten nicht
das geht nicht mehr wo man sich denn
heute gleich einig und wo gab es einen
heftigen streit zwischen den ländern
streit gab es gar nicht wir haben ja
sehr konzentriert miteinander getagt das
war eine kurze
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sie war
auch sehr gut vorbereitet und wir waren
uns in diesen punkten zb in dieser
impfpflicht für besondere bereiche sehr
schnell einig auch was das thema zweig
anbelangt dass wir das bundesweit
umsetzen wollen auch zweig plus bei
entsprechend höheren
infektionsgeschehen insofern gab es da
überhaupt kein problem wir haben
natürlich von seiten der länder auch
deutlich gemacht dass wir unterstützung
brauchen wir brauchen personelle
unterstützung jetzt für die impfzentren
die bundeswehr wird uns wieder helfen
aber das muss jetzt hand in hand gehen
bund und länder damit wir möglichst
schnell eine möglichst gute
infrastruktur haben um möglichst schnell
auch zu impfen erster und zweiter grund
auch die auffrischung kann man die
maßnahmen jetzt eigentlich ein lockdown
verunglimpften ja es wird ja oft so
genannte aber ich formuliere ist er
immer anders rum wir ermöglichen den
geimpften und den solidarischen einfach
sehr viel und das finde ich auch richtig
die muss man auch im blick behalten wir
reden sehr viel über diejenigen die
nicht geimpft sind sich aus welchen
gründen auch immer die ich gar nicht
nachvollziehen kann nicht impfen lassen
und diese 20 prozent dominieren unser
ganzes öffentliches leben wir alle
anderen müssen uns einschränken können
bestimmte dinge nicht so erleben wie wir
sie erleben wollen und wie es auch ganz
normal wäre weil es immer noch soviel
ungeimpfte gibt und jetzt wird das mal
umgedreht und wir sagen nein die
geimpften und genießen die ihnen die auf
sich und andere acht geben die können
bestimmte dinge erleben und
problematischer erleben und die
ungeimpften die müssen akzeptieren dass
es für sie einschränkungen gibt dann
sprechen wir über die geimpften
schließen sie einen allgemeinen lockt
dann also auch für geimpfte weiter aus
was passiert dann konkret nach dem
höchsten schwellenwert 9 man kann in
einer weltweiten pandemie vielleicht gar
nichts ausschließen aber ich glaube wir
haben alle möglichkeiten und alle
instrumente in der hand über einen lock
down zu verhindern denn wir haben ja die
impfmöglichkeiten wir haben die
impfzentren und die mobilen teams wir
wissen wie man mit abstand hygieneregeln
dinge sie sich auch im öffentlichen
leben schützen kann wie diese dinge
eingesetzt werden können wir haben mit
den zweig regeln jetzt zusätzliche
sicherheitsmaßnahmen und insofern glaube
ich wenn wir alle miteinander diese
dinge auch beachten besonnen sind die
impf angebote annehmen auch diese so
wichtige dritte auffrischungsimpfung
haben wir alle chancen
weitergehende maßnahmen zu verhindern
noch ganz kurz auf was für ein
weihnachtsfest müssen wir uns einstellen
wir müssen uns auf ein weihnachtsfest
einstellen wo wir eben auch wieder mit
diesen regeln uns auseinandersetzen
werden aber ich glaube ganz viele in den
familien wissen das und es ist ihm
bewusst dass es darauf ankommt eben auch
alle in der familie auch die älteren
auch diejenigen die noch keine impfung
in anspruch nehmen konnten die kinder
und jugendlichen zu schützen und dass
man natürlich weihnachten feiert man
muss sich nicht irgendwo einschließen
und verkriechen aber dass man natürlich
darauf achtet wie man feiert mit wem man
feiert das man es vielleicht im
kleineren rahmen macht das wissen sehr
viele dass es vernünftig ist und zu
können und werden wir auch die nächsten
wochen gemeinsam erleben dank michael
müller
nach einem fast sorglosen sommer in dem
man fast alles wieder oft fast nicht
kontrolliert geöffnet hat fürchten jetzt
clubs bars und restaurants wiederum ihr
geschäft aus düsseldorf alexander
hettich
und betriebsleiter immer nur kreidler
lässt nichts anbrennen impfpass oder
corona test ohne kommt man jetzt schon
nicht hinein ins lousiana er setzt
darauf dass die stimmung auch da nicht
kippt in der düsseldorfer altstadt wenn
du noch geimpfte und genesene kommen
dürfen
was wir jetzt festgestellt haben ist
dass die leute die wirklich nicht
geimpft sind auch gar nicht erst in die
stadt gehen jetzt auch die leute
wegfallen mit den tests dann wird
wahrscheinlich ruhig werden als
umsatzeinbußen ich gehe davon aus es ist
schon ruhiger geworden auf der
partymeile nur eine medizin messe spielt
noch ein paar leute in die kneipen die
verunsicherung ist spürbar auch bei
peter klinkhammer in der party location
spiegel hier drängt sich sonst das
feiervolk seit wochen aber kommen immer
weniger die 2g regel bringen wenigstens
klarheit meinte er
also die einschränkungen durch die
verunsicherung
stecke ich mich vielleicht doch an auch
wenn dann nur die ist mit sicherheit
sind die größer als die einschränkung
dass die leute die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollten nun zu hause bleiben doch
gerade in der jüngeren feiergemeinde ist
der ausschluss von ungeimpften selbst
mit test hochumstritten locker und
kontakt beschränkungen schmerzen hier
besonders vielen geht das alles zu weit
man ist komplett eingeschränkt komplett
einfach diese zweiklassengesellschaft
ist ein bisschen sehr extrem geworden
ich finds gut einfach weil es sicherer
ist ja sowieso doch geimpft und man hat
ein besseres gefühl wir haben einfach
eine meinungsfreiheit in deutschland
deswegen bin ich somit hat man nun gilt
es oder umgehen das ist ja die eigene
entscheidung und deswegen finde ich ein
bisschen unberechtigt
feiern nur noch unter scharfen auflagen
vielen jüngeren reicht's in der vierten
corona welle leert sich die sonst so
feierwütige düsseldorfer altstadt schon
jetzt für die gastronomen hier brechen
wieder einmal harte zeiten an
zugeschaltet ist jetzt der
gesundheitsexperte der grünen johannes
stammen guten abend guten abend worauf
müssen sich restaurants bars clubs denn
nun demnächst einstellen
ja zunächst mal ist heute mit dem
beschluss im deutschen bundestag
klarheit geschaffen worden das nun
flächendeckend zweig regeln in
deutschland möglich sind dass wir damit
einheitlich planbarkeit schaffen und vor
allem mehr schutz denn wir sind in einer
dramatischen notlage in einem ausmaß wie
wir sie bisher nicht erlebt haben und
jetzt muss wirklich mehr schutz dazu
helfen um diese vierte welle zu brechen
die union zeigte er mit dem neuen gesetz
das heute im bundestag beschlossen wurde
könnten die länder nicht mehr
beschließen kneipen und clubs zu
schließen stimmt es ja zunächst einmal
will ich vorweg schicken ich glaube
politik insgesamt hat sich heute keinen
gefallen getan wie wir in einem zank
zwischen unterschiedlichen parteien im
deutschen bundestag uns mehr auf
politische debatten konzentriert haben
denn wirklich auf die lösung der krise
klar ist dass das was bisher an
maßnahmen ergriffen wurde nicht dazu
gereicht hat diese vierte welle zu
verhindern und die infektions dynamik zu
brechen mit dem gesetz heute werden
zusätzliche maßnahmen 2 g.de 2g plus
habe ich gerade schon an brauchen aber
auch 3g am arbeitsplatz 3g im nah und
fernverkehr home office pflicht
kostenlose tests und vieles mehr auf den
weg gebracht das brauchen wir dringend
aber ich glaube auch es kann nur ein
erster schritt sein und im moment kann
man nichts ausschließen die situation
ist gerade im süden und osten
deutschlands so sehr ausgeprägt dass wir
mindestens um regionale lockdown star
nicht mehr drum herum kommen werden das
heißt sie glauben nicht dass die heute
beschlossenen maßnahmen ausreichen
werden um die vierte welle in den griff
zu bekommen ich glaube es werden eine
ganze reihe weiterer auch
gesetzgeberische schritte auf
bundesebene folgen wir werden
beispielsweise über das impfen in
apotheken reden müssen wir werden über
eine einrichtung spezifische impfpflicht
treten müssen aber ganz wichtig ist dass
jetzt der gesetzesrahmen der heute
geschaffen wird von den ländern auch
umgesetzt wird wir haben eine geltende
gesetzeslage die jetzt durch ein neues
gesetz im dezember abgelöst wird das
muss jetzt in maßnahmen vor ort auch
übersetzt werden die müssen durchgesetzt
werden es bringen die besten regeln es
nicht wenn sie keine anwendung findet
hier sind die länder in der pflicht
gerade dort wo die fallzahlen so hoch
sind und am ende des tages sind alle
eine mögliche neue bundesregierung eine
geschäftsführende bundesregierung und
bund und ländern gemeinsam in einem boot
die menschen dürfen erwarten dass sich
jetzt konsequent gekümmert wird weil ich
noch mal ich kann nur sagen die
situation auf den intensivstationen ist
so besorgniserregend dass wir neben
schutzmaßnahmen neben mehr impfen auch
nicht umher kommen werden patienten aus
diesen sehr betroffenen regionen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen in die weniger
betroffenen regionen im nordwesten des
landes zu verlegen vielen dank janosch
dahmen
ja so und bei mir ist jetzt attacke die
leiterin unserer redaktion recht und
justiz
sarah was steht denn da drin in diesem
neuen gesetz das heute im bundestag
beschlossen wurde was dürfen denn die
länder jetzt noch und was können sie
nicht mehr da steht unglaublich viel
drin und ich glaube es hilft das ganze
in drei zentrale aussagen entschuldigung
zu gliedern die einen zeit scheidende
aussage ist und dass es auch endlich der
hauptkritikpunkt was alles nicht mehr
geht es dürfen keine ausgangssperren
mehr hängt werden es können nicht mehr
flächendeckend alle kneipen restaurants
hotels und schulen geschlossen werden es
kann keine reiseverbote mehr geben es
kann nicht mehr untersagt werden sport
zu machen also diese ganzen maßnahmen
die man wenn sie zusammengenommen
stattfinden als sogenannte lock down
maßnahmen er bezeichnet die kann es
nicht mehr geben ich begebe mich nicht
für uns absolut gar nicht mehr dass eine
der zentralen aussagen auch nicht nur
regional auch nicht mehr regional die
die wird es nicht mehr geben also kein
bundesland kann diese maßnahmen ausrufen
das ist der stand wenn das neue gesetz
in kraft tritt aber der bund hat und das
ist der zweite die zweite zentrale
ausnahme vier maßnahmen beschlossen die
direkt bundesweit gelten dass es einmal
das nur noch geimpfte genesen und
getestete zur arbeit kommen dürfen das
nur noch geimpfte genesen und getestete
u bahn und bus fahren dürfen und daran
anknüpfend an die arbeit anknüpfen auch
verfertigte home office pflichten
nämlich dass man das dass ein
arbeitnehmer einen anspruch auf home
office hat das nur aus zwingenden
betrieblichen gründen home office
untersagt werden kann es eine sehr sehr
hohe hürde und das sind die neuen
bundesweiten maßnahmen mit denen der
bund die vierte welle brechen will und
dann die dritte zentrale aussage ist
dass dass das was wir schon kennen
weiter gilt also es können weiterhin
kontakt beschränkungen verhängt werden
es kann weiterhin dazu angehalten werden
die maske zu tragen es kann weiterhin 2g
3g vorschriften geben um auch die
restaurants hotel zu schulen offen
halten zu können das heißt es kann
weiterhin maßnahmen geben die wir schon
kennen beschlossen wurde dass das gesagt
3g am arbeitsplatz da gibt es ja viele
konkrete fragen zb wer zahlt den test
und gilt die testzeit auch als
arbeitszeit die testzeit ist ganz klar
keine arbeitszeit der arbeitnehmer muss
getestet zur arbeit kommen und selbst
wenn der arbeitgeber einen test zur
verfügung stellt heißt das dass man das
vor dienstantritt machen muss und die
tests werden zwei müssen muss der
arbeitgeber übernehmen auch schon jetzt
eine soll zukünftig der bund wieder
übernehmen das ist beschlossen und dann
bleiben noch zwei übrig die dann im
zweifel der arbeitnehmer selber zahlen
muss das ist wirklich viele fragen danke
sagt
ja ungefähr zwei drittel der deutschen
sind inzwischen doppelt geimpft mit dem
impfstoff so die hoffnung ist ein ende
der pandemie in sicht doch die zahl der
ungeimpften ist hoch und im durchbrüche
verunsichern nochmals wenn jan
bergerhoff mit zahlen und fakten
eine erschreckend hohe sieben tage
incidents mit fast 1400 70 unter den
ungeimpften veröffentlicht heute der
freistaat bayern eines der momentan am
stärksten betroffenen bundesländer doch
auch bei den geimpften steigt die sieben
tage incidents im freistaat auf 109,7
zunehmende impft durchbrüche
verunsichern zurzeit viele doch dass
diese auftreten sei ganz normal sagen
experten eine impfung bringt keine 100
prozentige sicherheit im kontext
insgesamt steigender fallzahlen steigt
auch die wahrscheinlichkeit für geimpfte
mit infizierten in kontakt zu kommen und
somit auch die wahrscheinlichkeit für
impf durchbrüche das heißt aber nicht
dass die impfungen nicht wirksam sind
sie schützen vor allem vor schweren
verläufen sehr gut geimpfte sind auf den
deutschen intensivstationen weiterhin in
der minderheit daten aus thüringen
zeigen dass die geimpften
intensivpatienten dort derzeit alle über
60 jahre sind und meist vorerkrankungen
haben diese gruppe war auch unter
denjenigen die im frühjahr zuerst
geimpft wurden ihr im schutz lässt
inzwischen nach
die wirkung der impfstoffe lässt nach
einigen monaten nach deshalb wird eine
auffrischungsimpfung empfohlen doch
nachdem viele im center im sommer
geschlossen wurden gibt es inzwischen
vielerorts lange schlangen zum beispiel
vor mobilen impfdosen an ada
mainz innenstadt der im bus ist da seit
9 uhr wird hier geimpft trotz
temperaturen deutlich unter zehn grad
stehen die menschen an egal ob jung oder
alt einen halben kilometer lang ist die
schlange wartezeit schon zu beginn
zwischen zwei und drei stunden
zeit 48 stehen wieder entsetzlich die
meisten die hier stehen wollen sich ihre
booster impfung abholen
dass die impfzentren geschlossen wurden
sehr sehr ärgerlich muss ich sagen ich
bin grundschullehrerin hab tagtäglich
die kinder zwischen fünf und zehn jahren
um mich herum die jetzt gerade am
meisten sich durch corona infizieren und
ich würde mich gerne boostern lassen
nicht ganz nachzuvollziehen warum ich
jetzt wieder wie bei stunde null ist
alle müssen warten mich regt auf dass
immer nur reagiert wird und nicht agiert
wird werden hier in der landeshauptstadt
hier müssten zehn busse stehen oder
nachdem man einmal hier diese
katastrophe gesehen hat müsste die
landesregierung morgen zehn busse in
mainz aufstellen ab kommender woche
sollen acht der neun ins zentren in
rheinland-pfalz wieder ihren betrieb
aufnehmen höchste zeit wenn man diesen
antrag sieht
dafür waren die im bus auch eigentlich
nicht konzipiert wir waren ursprünglich
als unterstützung für die impfzentren
gedacht
an dem antrag heute und auch bei
einsätzen der letzten zwei drei wochen
sieht man dass der ansturm teilweise
doch stark übersteigt was wir leisten
können mehr als 400 dosen biontech rund
50 dosen johnson johnson sind heute an
bord des busses gegen halb zwölf dann
die ernüchternde nachricht der impfstoff
von bayer und weg ist fast alle
sie können gerne warten es kann nicht
versprechen dass sie noch gehen
wie lange man hier noch nicht
wenn sie jetzt auf eigenes risiko hier
stehen mindestens zwei drei stunden es
könnten auch hier seien es ist ja
wunderbar halten sollte
trotzdem die meisten leute bleiben die
hoffnung mit dem booster packs im arm
nach hause zu gehen überwiegt und
darüber reden möchte ich jetzt mit dem
infektionsforscher professor meyer
hermann hermann hermann wie wichtig ist
denn die dritte impfung die so genannte
booster impfung
man muss sich erst mal klar machen dass
die ganze anime bewältigung auf der
impfung insgesamt aufbaut das ist unsere
chance und ist eigentlich ein wunder
dass wir so schnell einen solchen teilen
impfstoff bekommen haben der quasi keine
nebenwirkungen hat und der so gut wirkt
aber dennoch ist es so dass nach zwei
impfungen über die monate hinweg der
impfschutz abnimmt und man durch die
dritte impfung jetzt in der lage ist den
impfschutz wieder hochzufahren das
schützt nicht nur vor schlägern
verläufen sondern auch wo der infektion
selbst und dadurch kann man die impf
wirkung auf die pandemie entwicklung
sehr gut starten
gesetzt den fall man könnte jetzt
wirklich schnell alle zum dritten mal
impfen kann man damit diese hohe zahl
von menschen die sich weiterhin nicht
impfen lassen wollen ausgleichen
kann man nicht also es ist ziemlich
eindeutig wir haben 75 prozent der
infektionen die von den ungeimpften
ausgehen und dabei muss man sich
vergegenwärtigen dass es nur ein drittel
der bevölkerung ist also das heißt wir
haben ein deutlich höheres risiko
dass die impfung namik von den
ungeimpften weitergetragen wird und es
ist ja auch so dass die umkämpften die
entsprechenden krankenhäuser und die
intensivstationen füllen und insofern
ist es einfach sehr bedauerlich dass es
so viele ungeübte noch gibt in
deutschland man sollte sich wirklich
klar machen dass das risiko an der
impfung irgendeine nebenwirkungen zu
bekommen so unglaublich viel kleiner ist
als das risiko dass man eingeht wenn man
die virusinfektion selbst hat und
insofern kann ich nur jedem dazu
aufrufen dennoch zögert jetzt sofort zur
sich impfen zu lassen reicht die
maßnahmen die heute beschlossen wurden
denn ihrer meinung nach aus was wäre
dennoch sinnvoll
also zum thema impfen kann ich dazu noch
sagen dass impfen hilft uns jetzt in
dieser krise in dieser vierten battle
erstmal überhaupt nicht wenn wir uns
jetzt alle impfen lassen und die
impfquote hochbringen dann hilft uns das
im januar februar im moment ist es so
dass wir die vierte welle brechen müssen
und die vierte welle ist in einer
dynamik unterwegs das haben wurde ja
gerade an berichten auch geschrieben die
nicht von schlechten eltern ist wir
müssen einfach zusehen dass wir diese
welle brechen und ich bin sehr sehr
betrübt darüber dass die politik so
lange gebraucht hat um überhaupt zu
reagieren denn das erste was man in der
akademie bekämpfung machen muss ist
schnell reagieren und wir haben jetzt
eine situation gehabt in der die eine
regierung nicht mehr reagiert hat und
die neue regierung eher verharmlost hat
also den regierung insb mit solchen
kommentaren wie es wird keine lockt das
mehr geben und auch mit der unglaublich
absurden idee dass man jetzt die
pandemische lage auslaufen lässt in
einer situation wo wir die höchsten
instanz in der gesamten pandemie
geschichte deutschlands haben das ist
eigentlich und verantwortung das ist
verantwortungslos weil es natürlich das
falsche signal die quilt bevölkerung
schickt und wir hängen alle davon ab
dass wir alle verstehen dass wir jetzt
vorsichtig sein müssen das heißt die
signale sind extrem wichtig in der
pandemie bekämpfung und es ist sehr
bedauerlich dass es so lange gedauert
hat wenn ja ist maßnahmen genau anschaut
das war ja ihre frage dann wissen wir
aus österreich das 2g alleine nicht
reicht um die infektions tsunami kinder
atmen wir sie jetzt erleben
unterzubringen und das ist der nächste
fehler den ich sehe in der
brandbekämpfung in dem moment wo die
instanzen explodieren ist das nicht der
moment wo man den maßnahmenkatalog
reduziert sondern seien alle
möglichkeiten haben die dann im register
hat um reagieren zu können den appell
verstanden vielen dank professor meyer
hermann
ja wie reagieren andere länder auf die
pandemie wie viel druck gibt es office
unwillige welche maßnahmen wirken ein
blick nach israel großbritannien und
italien
porter auf brötchen ein normaler imbiss
in italien normalität hat gastwirt mario
panino schätzen gelernt seit der korona
krise die lage in italien ist jetzt
unter kontrolle
dafür akzeptiert er gerne dass er nur
gäste die geimpft getestet oder genesen
sind empfangen kann
ich habe schöne sitzplätze im freien
dort muss sich die gäste nicht
kontrollieren aber natürlich wenn sie
reinkommen habe ich die kontrolle auf
meinem handy bereit
schon seit mitte oktober gilt der
sogenannte greenpeace also 3g fast
überall sogar am arbeitsplatz
arbeitgeber die nicht kontrollieren
müssen strafe zahlen arbeitnehmer ohne
nachweis mit lohnausfall rechnern corona
tests sind kostenpflichtig maßnahmen die
bisher halfen so ist die lage auf den
intensivstationen derzeit entspannt doch
die zahl der neu infizierten stieg
zuletzt die regierung draghi plan und
strengere regeln
dieser heimtückischen feind klopft
andauernd lektüre und wir müssen noch
mehr schutz gegen ihn aufbauen
eine art super greenpeace könnte das
werden der nach der impfung nur sechs
oder neun monate gilt der mann dann per
booster auffrischt oder das nur noch pcr
tests als negativ nachweis gelten viele
finden das richtig wir müssen tun was
möglich ist sonst kommen wir da nie raus
dann schließen sie uns wieder ein und
wer weiß wie das ändert wie
neuinfizierten sind fast alle ungeimpft
sodass wir zumindestens mit der impfung
versuchen diese ruhe zu schaffen die wir
dieses jahr erlebten vor allem
weihnachten und wintersaison will man
retten dafür nimmt italien schärfere
regeln in kauf
es lebt sich recht ungeniert in england
seit dem juli die korona beschränkungen
aufgehoben wurden trotz instanzen
zwischen 350 und 500 die zahlen
verharren auf hohem niveau das impf
tempo land top mediziner warnen die
situation könnte außer kontrolle geraten
fordern zurück zur masken pflicht zum
home office gebot zu mehr vorsicht davon
hält der premier nicht boris johnson als
bittsteller wieder mehr ärmel
hochkrempeln seine botschaft der kampf
gegen den abnehmenden schutz bei
geimpften und weiter unwilligen wird
allein mit appellen geführt
im moment sehen wir in der entwicklung
der korona zahlen noch kein anlass für
neue beschränkungen aber wir können
nichts ausschließen also holt euch die
auffrischung spritze
die größte sorge eine drohende
grippewelle plus steigende corona zahlen
der kollaps des gesundheitssystems wäre
schnell erreicht was hilft im vergleich
zu deutschland haben sich bislang viel
mehr menschen angesteckt ein natürlicher
schutz bezahlt mit der höchsten zahl an
toten in europa viele länder haben
großbritannien in sachen impfquote
überholt obwohl man hier früher los
gelegt hatte was nun zum bumerang wird
denn bei den flügen hat der schutz stark
nachgelassen
wenn das booster programm erfolgreich
verläuft sehr viele sich erneut impfen
lassen dann können wir das risiko für
millionen menschen im krankenhaus zu
landen oder zu sterben deutlich
verringern nicht nur für die
weihnachtszeit sondern für den gesamten
winter
die hoffnung dass die appelle des
premiers die impf begeisterung wieder
entfachen und das reicht um über die
dunkle jahreszeit voller düsterer
prognosen zu kommen ohne erneuten
weihnachts lockdown
ein wenig wundern sich auch die israelis
was ihr land so viel besser macht als
andere
eine massive vierte welle liegt hinter
ihnen überstanden ganz ohne noch dauern
das bunte treiben auf dem kabelmarkt in
tel aviv lief die ganze zeit weiter
ich möchte ja nichts schlechtes über die
europäer sagen aber hier sind die
menschen schneller angespannt immer wenn
ein problem auftaucht oder eine
bedrohung sind sie alarmiert deshalb
verstehen sie das schnell gar nicht
werden muss
wir sind diese dinge gewohnt alle gehen
gemeinsam forum das so schnell wie
möglich zu überstehen in dem moment als
wir verstanden dass impfungen die lösung
sind hat sich die große mehrheit impfen
lassen schon früh setzte die regierung
auf entschlossenes handeln auf die
dritte impfung eine entscheidung die
bereits vor vier monaten fiel in einer
beherzten kampagne wurden seither vier
millionen menschen fast aller
altersgruppen gepustet jetzt sind die
impfzentren wieder leer ich kam letztes
jahr nach israel mitten in corona und
mitten im lockdown alle haben genug es
ist zeit für die impfung und es scheint
als bekämen sie alle
unter sind israels hocheffektive
krankenkassen mit eigenem personal und
eigener infrastruktur
wir haben den impfstoff für jeden
erreichbar und erhältlich gemacht indem
wir zum beispiel gezielt die ältere
generation angesprochen haben mit haus
terminen vor ort wo wir dann geimpft
haben
ab nächster woche werden in israel
übrigens die fünf- bis elfjährigen
geimpft seit der freigabe des impfstoffs
in den usa vergingen gerade mal drei
wochen
bei mir ist nun der
politikwissenschaftler karl rudolf korte
guten haben sehr gut wir haben gesehen
in israel wurde schnell gehandelt es gab
schnell die dritte impfung in italien
wurde sehr schnell auch 3g eingeführt
warum das bist bei uns bisher nicht nur
wir haben eine umarmung demokratie kann
man nicht durchregieren hier sind viele
im föderalen gebildet zu beteiligen
deshalb dauert es länger aber am ende
ist die entscheidung auch befriedet wir
bewerten sie heute die ergebnisse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dieses
instrument ist eigentlich nicht geeignet
und die krise am ende auch zu bewältigen
wir brauchen eigentlich ein krisenstab
dafür bräuchten wir ein neues gesetz
denn diese ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
führt ja nicht indem sie verantwortung
übernimmt sondern in der regel er auch
im vorfeld dass man schuldige gesucht
sofern hat die politik in der reaktion
auf die krise nicht mit dem richtigen
instrument bisher aus meiner sicht
reagiert wie schwer belasteten diese
krise den start für die ampel sehr denn
sie wollen ja aufbruch inszenieren
inhaltlicher art und uns in diesen
aufbruch auch mit führen da kann man
sich nicht so kann man nicht so tun als
hätte man mit corona wenig zu tun und
muss auch ein aufbruch für corona
politik organisieren das wird schwer
wenn es nicht nur in moll tönen wie sehr
hat denn dieses machtvakuum in der
korona krise jetzt geschadet eigentlich
haben wir kein formales machtvakuum eine
geschäfts regierung die aktiv ist aber
man müsste verantwortung im sinne von
führung übernehmen entweder im duo
merkel scholz oder einer und so fern ist
im moment nicht sichtbar wer konkret die
verantwortung für führung übernehmen
möchte formal haben wir kein vakuum
vielen dank für diese einschätzung klar
doch konnte
ja das war unser zdf spezial aber
natürlich sind noch viele fragen offen
die heute auch bei maybrit illner
diskutiert werden mehr informationen
jederzeit unter zdf heute oder später im
heute journal wie geht es jetzt weiter
mit den bergrettern einen schönen abend
noch auf wiedersehen
[Musik]